l'art de la récupération c'est
l'exposition xylo morphose de collines
ou bear bois semelles de chaussures
capsules de bière tout est réutilisé
pour construire des villes des
personnages et des bateaux imaginaire
l'artiste ramasse tout et partout et
parkings bord de mer montagne et même
des airs l'origine de l'exposition xylo
morphose de la médiathèque de
voisins-le-bretonneux est particulière
j'ai été contacté par le parcours a
expliqué dent pour est exposée dans une
chapelle et j'expose à la chapelle
desclaux et comme je voulais pas
travailler sur un thème religieux j'ai
choisi le thème de la solidarité et
j'avais lu le bouquin de laurent gaudé
qui s'appelle el dorado et j'en ai
profité pour travailler ce thème toucher
particulièrement et j'ai travaillé là
sur le thème des migrants
et
il
qui
des bateaux de migrants créé après de
longues heures de travail chaque morceau
ramassé est utilisée par l'artiste qui
sait exactement à quoi cela va servir
pauline boubet repenser des coûts écoles
tous ces matériaux dans son atelier de
chevreuse un travail accessible à tous
le fait que les gens puissent se
l'approprier facilement et ça a
déclenché eu des émotions souvent qui
sont parfois inattendus et ça permet de
rentrer quand je suis présent dans les
expositions et j'essaye de le plus
souvent d'être d'être là pour justement
rencontrer le public
ça permet de lui des discussions et une
ouverture au dialogue qui est
intéressante ce trône pour les plus
curieux
il est possible de visiter l'atelier sur
simple rendez vous